Traductor: Larisa Esteche
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
¿Se acuerdan de su salón
de 6º de primaria?
¿Se acuerdan de quién era su maestra,
sus amigos, del olor como a papel y lápiz?
¿Se acuerdan quién era el niño o niña
más burro de su clase?
Les puedo apostar que esa misma persona
era quien leía mal en voz alta.
Y lo que pasa es que entre 1º y 4º
de primaria, más o menos,
nos enseñan a leer.
Nos enseñan a juntar letras
para formar palabras,
y a juntar palabras para formar oraciones,
y a juntar oraciones para formar párrafos.
La cosa es que por ahí en 5°,
la relación se invierte.
Y dejamos de aprender a leer
para leer para aprender.
Y entonces ahí se hace obvio algo que
conocemos como la brecha de aprendizaje.
Los niños que leen bien, avanzan.
Los que no, empiezan a quedarse atrás.
Yo soy Irma, y soy chilanga,
y como muchos de Uds. probablemente,
y como millones de personas,
crecí en la ciudad de México
en los 80 y los 90.
Desde muy chica me di cuenta
de que en esta ciudad
convivían muchos mundos, muy diferentes.
Mi mundo personal, el propio,
aunque sin muchos lujos,
fue súper privilegiado.
Crecí en una familia
donde nunca me faltó nada.
Siempre fui a la escuela,
nunca tuve hambre, nunca tuve frío,
y siempre tuve libros.
Y la cosa es que a mí, desde muy chica,
tal vez porque crecí en una familia
muy empática
y tal vez porque tengo un interés propio
en lo social,
pero desde siempre me ha interesado
la desigualdad.
Y me interesa conocerla,
me la he cuestionado,
incluso he tratado de solucionarla.
En mi vida profesional y académica
siempre me he dedicado a temas sociales.
Pero con toda esa experiencia
y contando que llevo más de 30 años
en esta ciudad,
explicar qué es la desigualdad
a mi hija, por ejemplo,
me cuesta mucho trabajo.
Me cuesta mucho trabajo decirle
qué es y por qué está ahí, por qué existe.
Porque es fea.
Es difícil para mí.
Pero regresemos a su salón
de 5º de primaria.
Cuando estamos en un salón,
es obvio quiénes no están aprendiendo,
quiénes se están quedando atrás.
Es muy fácil distinguirlos,
ahorita todos nos acordamos.
¿Pero qué pasa cuando queremos diferenciar
a las personas en una escuela?
¿Quiénes se están quedando atrás
en una escuela?
¿Y en una comunidad? ¿Y en un municipio?
¿Y en un estado? ¿Y en el país?
¿Quiénes son los que se están
quedando detrás?
Los que menos tienen.
¿Qué tiene que ver esto
con los niños de 5º de primaria, no?
Pues resulta que hace poco,
el mundo se dio cuenta
del desarrollo infantil temprano
y del desarrollo infantil oportuno,
seguro han escuchado de él.
Y parecemos habernos dado cuenta
de que los primeros años de vida
de una persona son cruciales.
Lo que comemos, las condiciones
en las que vivimos,
la estimulación
a la que estamos expuestos.
Todo eso se vuelven indicadores
de lo que va a ser nuestra vida
a mediano y largo plazo.
Para cuando llegamos a la escuela,
ya tuvimos un boom de desarrollo, ya pasó.
En esos primeros años de vida
que se conocen como primera infancia,
es cuando nuestro cerebro más crece,
cuando más elástico es,
cuando nuestras neuronas más se conectan.
Y entonces ahí está la posibilidad
de hacer una diferencia.
Porque podríamos usar esa primera infancia
para lograr que todos los niños
de 5º de primaria puedan aprender mejor,
puedan aprender de lo que leen
y puedan estar en igualdad de condiciones.
¿Pero cómo hacemos?
¿Cómo hacemos para que desde
la primera infancia podamos ayudar
a estos niños a estar listos
para aprender?
Libros. Lo hacemos con libros.
Los libros son una herramienta increíble
para estimular el desarrollo cognitivo,
de lenguaje, emocional y motor
de niños y de bebés.
Y no se lo digo yo que mi look favorito
es el de bibliotecaria en potencia,
no es por eso.
En serio, no. Es porque los libros
tienen un potencial increíble
de hacer una diferencia real en la vida
de una persona.
El acceso a libros en el hogar
puede marcar una diferencia importante,
muy importante en la vida de un niño.
John ... que es un bibliotecario,
él dice que la lectoescritura
es una habilidad bandera.
O sea, que promueve otras habilidades.
Y yo no podría estar más de acuerdo
con él, la verdad, porque los libros
efectivamente promueven habilidades
de decodificación, de estructura,
de conocimiento del mundo, de imaginación,
de creatividad,
de familiaridad con la palabra escrita.
El acceso a libros en el hogar, además,
y no el acceso a libros en bibliotecas,
por ejemplo,
hace una diferencia súper importante
y tiene un impacto muy positivo
en la vida de los niños.
Hay un estudio, por ejemplo,
que es un estudio internacional
que se realizó en más de 27 países
con un montón de variables,
en el que se concluyó que tener libros
en la primera infancia en la casa
tiene un impacto directo
en la escolaridad, en el nivel escolar,
que va a alcanzar ese niño o niña.
Y además, este impacto no es transversal,
no es generalizado para toda la población.
Este impacto es considerablemente mayor
en aquellas familias de escasos recursos,
y en aquellas familias con padres y madres
de niveles escolares bajos.
Eso significa que quienes más necesitan
los libros son quienes menos tienen.
Y, cuando yo caí en cuenta
de todo esto me, me explotó el cerebro.
Me explotó el cerebro
porque llevaba muchos años
tratando de que mi trabajo
tuviera un impacto real,
generara un cambio,
pudiera ser más grande que yo.
Y cuando me di cuenta de que un libro
tenía la posibilidad de lograr eso,
mi cabeza explotó.
Seguro ya para este momento
se dan cuenta de que los libros y yo
somos cercanos.
Me gustan muchísimo los libros,
me encantan las historias,
me gusta mucho leer,
compro muchos más libros
de los que necesito,
de los que puedo leer en mi tiempo libre.
Soy fan. Los libros son hermosos.
Pero no es nada más
porque los libros sean hermosos
por lo que yo creo que todo el mundo
debería tener acceso a ellos.
Se los digo porque desde mi corazón
politólogo y nerd,
me di cuenta de que la evidencia
estaba ahí.
Y de que los libros pueden
efectivamente hacer una diferencia.
Cuando caí en cuenta de que esto
era una posibilidad real,
de que es alcanzable que todos los niños
tengan libros en su casa,
entonces me decidí.
Me decidí, dejé mi trabajo
y dejé las políticas públicas,
invertí el poco dinero que tenía
y convencí a mi socia
de invertir el poco dinero que ella tenía
y a mi esposo de darnos un poquito más,
y de endeudarnos un poco.
Y después de muchas metidas de pata,
discusiones, libros sobre primera infancia
y sobre desarrollo, sobre generación
de impacto social,
creamos Ateconqueso.
Ateconqueso es una empresa social
que nació aquí en México,
que promueve el acceso a libros infantiles
en todos los hogares mexicanos.
Para lograr eso, hacemos libros increíbles
que, en serio son increíbles,
y además tenemos un modelo uno a uno
en el que por cada libro que vendemos
regalamos el mismo libro
a una familia en desventaja.
En Ateconqueso creemos que todos los niños
deberían tener las mismas oportunidades
de aprender.
Y para lograr eso estamos convencidas
de que todos los niños
y cada uno de esos niños
tiene que tener libros en su casa
desde el primer momento de su vida.
Este momento en el que les decía
que a mí me explotó el cerebro,
y me moría de emoción,
ese momento creo que me llegó
cuando pude entender los libros
como una posibilidad alcanzable
de generar un cambio,
de generar el cambio
que yo había estado buscando
desde hacía mucho tiempo,
desde que me di cuenta de las diferentes
realidades que vivían en mi ciudad.
Cuando me di cuenta de eso
fue como, en serio,
fue como si mi cerebro explotara.
Porque los libros de la nada
se multiplicaron,
se convirtieron en objetos de juego,
de estimulación.
Se convirtieron en juguetes, en torres,
en telescopios, en arte.
Se convirtieron en risas,
en momentos compartidos.
Y por sobre todo eso,
se convirtieron en detonadores de cambio.
Fue cuando me di cuenta de que los libros
son detonadores de cambio
cuando me decidí y cuando me di cuenta
de que yo tenía una posibilidad real
de cambiar el rumbo de mi país.
Porque los libros tienen esta...
tienen esta ventaja
de que pueden estar en todos lados.
Los podemos poner en manos
de quien queramos.
Y cuando todas las cosas se juntaron,
entonces me di cuenta de que mi misión
de vida y la de Ateconqueso
se estaban alineando.
Y se habían alineado para intentar
y para dedicarnos
a ver si podíamos reducir la desigualdad
a través de los libros.
Cuando yo le contaba de esto a una amiga,
hace relativamente poco,
cuando le contaba toda la historia
de Ateconqueso,
ella me decía, "Pues sí,
todo me hace sentido. Tienes razón.
Pero entonces no entiendo
por qué como sociedad
insistimos en regalar
a los bebés calcetines.
¿Por qué no les regalamos algo
que tenga el potencial
de cambiar su vida?".
Y sí, por qué no.
Si todos los niños tuvieran libros
en su casa,
podríamos cambiar una generación completa.
Podríamos crear una generación de niños
curiosos, de niños creativos,
de niños que puedan aprender.
Podríamos generar un montón de niños
que estén listos para aprender
en 5º de primaria.
Yo estoy convencida.
Juntos podemos cambiar el rumbo
de nuestro país un libro a la vez.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.